hi my name is yunju i'm a master's
student in the systems medicine program
at georgetown
this is my final project for my machine
learning course and it's on using
unsupervised clustering to examine
multiple classes of opioid use disorder
patients
opioid use disorder is a chronic
physical and psychological dependence on
opiates leading to clinically
significant impairment or distress
biologically is characterized by a
rewiring of the brain's pleasure centers
shown here
when a cortex has received a stimulus
such as an opioid it sends a signal to
the ventral tegmental area which then
releases dopamine into the nucleus
accumbens amygdala and the prefrontal
cortex
the nucleus accumbens then activates
motor function while the prefrontal
cortex focuses attention to the
pleasurable sensations brought by the
stimulus
there are both genetic risk factors that
can make someone more susceptible to
addiction in the first place as well as
environmental factors such as
accessibility to opiates and other
stressful environmental situations have
pushed people to resort to opiate use
the prevalence of oud has significantly
increased since the early 2000s and
there is currently an oud epidemic in
the united states
with the onset of the cobit 19 pandemic
opiate use has become even more
widespread likely due to the financial
medical and social difficulties that
have been
amplified
consequently there is a huge unmet need
to better understand the impacts of oud
on the brain
for my project i utilize this gene
expression omnibus transcriptomic data
set of 80 samples consisting of 20
control nucleus accumbens samples 20
control dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
20 oud nucleus accumbens and 20 oud
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex samples
there are 60
676 genes total in this data set
these are the methods that i used first
since protein coding rna and long
non-coding rna have separate expression
profiles they were analyzed separately
so the data set was
filtered for either protein coding rna
or long non-coding rna based on gene
names from ensembl biomart for each
subset of data data was annotated with
corresponding metadata containing
clinical characteristics of each sample
such as oud diagnosis and brain region
then data exploration was conducted
using differential gene expression
analysis
and results were displayed using a
volcano plot
significant genes were filtered and
samples were first clustered using a
heat map analysis
principal component analysis was
conducted to explore the variance of
samples in the data set and pca results
were displayed
with scatter plots
unsupervised clustering with affinity
propagation was used to assess how
samples clustered together based on
significant genes
for each cluster the grouped samples
were extracted and clusters were further
explored using differential gene
expression analysis
a few clusters characterized by all or
mostly control samples
in either dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
or nucleus accumbens brain regions were
grouped together to act as a control for
clusters of oud samples with the goal of
minimizing confounding effects by brain
region
ensemble names were converted to gene
names using the my gene python package
and top significant genes were inputted
into enricher to assess pathway
involvement in select clusters
all data analysis was carried out in
python on a google collab script file
provided at the end of this presentation
that can be readily run to generate the
results from this project
for protein coding rna differential gene
expression analysis revealed 183
significantly altered genes in oud with
147 upregulated and 36 down regulated
genes
heat map analysis of the samples
revealed a cluster of oud samples
characterized by upregulation of several
significant genes
principal component analysis suggested
large amounts of noise within the oud
and control samples and samples were
grouped by brain region rather than oud
diagnosis
the pca accounted for approximately 46
percent of the variance in the data and
noise variance was 6.54
affinity propagation unsupervised
clustering of the significant data
resulted in 11 clusters
cluster 3 only contained one sample and
clusters 6 7 and 10 contained
approximately equal amounts of oud and
control samples
the remaining clusters were further
analyzed using differential expression
and pathway enrichment analysis tool in
richer
clusters one and two each contained oud
samples only in the nucleus accumbens
regions and cluster four contained
control samples only in the also only in
the nucleus of cummins region
consequently cluster four was used as a
control to compare clusters one and two
differential expression analysis using
this contrast revealed 229 significant
genes in cluster 1
and a
166 significant genes in cluster 2 with
92 of these genes overlapping between
the two clusters
strikingly clusters wanted to appear to
be characterized by significantly
different pathways based on enricher
analysis
while cluster 1 involved il-6 jack stat3
and il-2-5
and tnf-alpha and f-kappa b signaling
shown here
cluster 2
tended to involve a variety of pathways
including nicotine addiction signaling
wind signaling and the ras pathway
clusters 8 and 9 also contain only oud
samples but from
both dorsolateral prefrontal cortex and
nucleus accumbens brain regions
on the other hand clusters 4 5 and 11
contain mostly control samples
when combined so the combination of
clusters 4 5 and 11 was used as a
control to further analyze clusters 8
and 9.
based on this contrast cluster 8 had 191
significant genes
while cluster 9 had 57 and 36 of these
genes overlapped between the two
these two clusters appeared to be
involved in largely similar inflammatory
pathways including sedicon receptor
interaction
il-6 jack stat3
il-2 step 5 and tnf-alpha and if kappa b
signaling
to check for any differences
differential gene expression was also
examined between these two clusters
which resulted in 68 significantly
altered genes in cluster 9 compared to
cluster 8.
analysis of these genes using enricher
indicated pathways involved in mineral
absorption and response to metal ions as
well as some of the inflammatory
pathways found previously such as tiana
f alpha and nfc b signaling
similar methods were applied for the
subset of data containing only long
non-coding rna
for long non-coding rna there were 93
significant
significantly altered genes in oud with
63 upregulated and 30 down regulated in
lud
just as in the protein coding analysis
heat map analysis of the significant
long non-coding rna revealed general
separation of a cluster of oud samples
though it appeared to be less clear than
in the protein coding rna data set
eca showed that reduced dimensions
accounted for a very low percentage of
the variance in long encoding rna data
at only 19
with a noise variance of 9.06 and
samples again tended to be grouped by
brain region rather than oud diagnosis
unsupervised clustering of data using
affinity propagation resulted in nine
clusters
clusters two and eight contained only
one sample and cluster three contained
almost equal amounts of oud and control
samples
clusters 1 4 and 7 contained mostly oud
samples from both brain regions
whereas clusters 5 6 and 9 contain
mostly control samples when combined
consequently the combination of clusters
5 6 and 9 were used as a control to
compare clusters 1 4 and 7.
cluster 1 contained 160 significant
genes
cluster 4 contained 29 significant genes
and cluster 7 contained 22.
while there was no overlap between
clusters 4 and 7 there were 13
overlapping long non-coding rna genes
between clusters 1 and 4 and 11
overlapping between
1 and 7.
the majority of the ensemble transcript
names could not be converted to gene
names using
the mygene package
likely due to a relative lack of
annotation of long non-coding rnas in
general
many of these transcripts appeared to be
novel or uncharacterized
as enriching results were inconclusive
and did not reveal significant pathway
involvement long non-coding rna genes
were manually examined for each cluster
using the ncbi gene database
cluster 1 has significant genes such as
serena2 and
mir210hg which are involved in microrna
regulation
part 1 which is induced by androgens and
prostate adenocarcinoma
and asthma-associated npsr-1 antisense
rna 1.
cluster 2 contains lyrs which interacts
with syncrypt to regulate mrna
metabolism and transport and il-21r
antisense rna1 which is involved in
immune responses
significant genes in cluster 3 included
a few more antisense rnas such as hip 1
alpha antisense rna3 and rho xf1
antisense rna1
in summary for both
for both protein coding and long
non-coding rna data sets data
exploration using differential gene
expression heat map analysis revealed up
regulation of several genes in oud and
some separation of a portion of oud
samples compared to control
however pca showed that the samples
tended to separate by brain region
rather than oud diagnosis
additionally it revealed that
dimensionality reduction accounts for a
very low percentage of the variance
found particularly in the long
non-coding rna data set
this may be due to the fact that long
non-coding rnas are more specific to
tissue type and are usually found in
lower concentrations leading to more
noise within the long non-coding rna
dataset
affinity propagation clustering of the
samples based on significant genes
resulted in 11 clusters when samples
were characterized by protein-coding rna
cluster 2 was particularly interesting
as it featured characteristics different
from the inflammation related pathways
present in other clusters despite the
fact that all oud samples were from
subjects who had been diagnosed with oud
for at least five years
this suggests that different oed
patients may respond better to different
therapies and points to the importance
of stratifying oud patients
in this project cluster 2 was
characterized by pathways involving camp
wind cholinergic signaling and uv
response
though it is unknown whether these
results are biologically relevant to
opiate addiction or are related to
additional clinical or environmental
factors such as substances lifestyles or
comorbidities they may provide insight
since oud is a multifactorial disease
further research should be done to
better understand the significance of
these mechanisms in oud
on the other hand long non-coding rna
filtered samples were clustered into
nine groups
three clusters contained mostly oud
samples
these clusters seem to feature micro rna
immune reproductive and epigenetic
related long non-coding rna genes but
enriching results remained inconclusive
due to a large portion of long
non-coding rnas with unknown function
and significance
however
some long non-coding rnas were among the
significant transcripts altered in oud
in the overall data set
and there there's increasing evidence
that long encoding rnas are important in
disease pathophysiology
an important future step in oud research
may be to functionally characterize a
long non-coding rna significantly
differentially altered in
oud
there were several limitations in the in
this project
there were multiple confounding factors
that this study did not account for
such as varying combinations and amounts
of subjects and
sub substances and subjects and systems
at the time of death or the presence of
other clinical disorders or
characteristics
this could have contributed for the
noise and variance within the dataset
despite the separate analysis
of protein coding and long non-coding
rna
additionally this project only utilized
one transcriptomic dataset
as oud is a multifactorial disease that
is significantly influenced by
environmental and epigenetic factors
this project provides a limited view
into the biological mechanism of oed
looking more comprehensively at other
data types such as dna methylation and
micro rna data might be useful as next
steps in understanding oud mechanisms
but overall the results in this analysis
suggest that inflammatory pathways are
enriched in oud with a subset of oud
patients experiencing other neurological
changes that may require different
interventions
chronic substance abuse is known to
activate various inflammatory processes
that are associated with neuropathology
beyond the direct action of the
substance on neurotransmitter signaling
these findings may support the use of
administering
anti-inflammatory therapies to alleviate
the cognitive and behavioral
manifestations of opiate addiction
and for patients that may not respond to
such therapies as is the case in many
clinical trials additional clinical
transcriptional genomic and epigenetic
data as well as increased
characterization of long non-coding rnas
may be valuable in providing more
precise treatment
these were my references
this eighth one is a publication that
originally generated and analyzed the
data set used in this project
thank you for listening i'd like to
thank mr brotzky for instructing our
machine learning course and for teaching
us all the concepts used in my project
in supporting our class
as well as pine biotech in the omixlogic
program
i'd also like to thank dr vasudevan the
program director for our systems
medicine program for being such a
supportive advisor
and finally
also my machine learning class
i've also included the link to my collab
python code here which contains all the
code for my project
thank you